[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار المغرب بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم زلزال بقوه سبعد درجات
على مقياس ريختر يهز المغرب العدد
الاجمالي لضحايا الزلزال يرتفع الى
1737 قتيلا
و721 مصابا وفقما نقله التلفزيون الرسمي
نقلا عن وزاره الداخليه فضلا عن اصابه
المئات حالات بعضهم خطيره ووصف المعهد
الوطني المغربي للجيو فيزياء هذا الزلزاله
بانه الاعنف منذ قرن اما عن الوضع الاغاثي
فقد ناشد مدير الهلال الاحمر المغربي
والمنسق الجهوي للاسعاف والاستعجال بمراكش
ناشد عبر الجزيره المواطنين التبرع بالدم
لتلبيه الحاجات الكبيره للجرحى
بالمستشفيات مضيفا في حديث للجزيره انه لا
يستطيع حتى الان معرفه عدد العالقين تحت
انقاض الزلزال على صعيد ردود الفعل
الدوليه والعربيه توالت المواقف الدوليه
والعربيه التي اعربت عن تضاملها مع الشعب
المغربي والتي ابدت استعدادها للمساعده
واعلنت السلطات الجزائريه فتح المجال
الجوي امام الرحلات الجويه لنقل المساعدات
الانسانيه والجرحى والمصابين الى اللقاء